good job let's go ahead and keep moving
we're gonna lunge to the side for one
one squeeze your abs a cackle a day
keeps the cankles away so Paul has a
much Daniel I do 30 of these a day it's
great for the ABS yeah I don't believe
in doing abdominal exercise
I don't know weightlifting is that bad
now can somebody tell me why women have
to make everything so much harder
just another CrossFit girl spending
Valentine's Day with her barbell now do
chin-ups and your oven mitts
breast cancer is never funny anybody
else will share yes my name is Daniel
and my hair is thinning and I'm really
allergic to cats and I'm dead inside
very good very good bunch of
disease-riddled snobs I'm more of a
laughter Pilates guy anyway
[Music]
well howdy prancercising princess it's
nice to meet you I appreciate you coming
my season starts in three days
and I need to get in tip-top shape well
prancercise is the answer I'm telling
you Daniel there's nothing like it only
have three days so I think I'm gonna
need larger weights is prancercising
based under love for horses what's not
to love strength endurance and mention
Carrie what's the best music to
prancercise - I love Motown you know the
prancercise walk first decide let's go
the track is similar to the walk
everyone should be prancercising
guys you don't prancercise your inspire
[Music]
thank you my body feels incredible
prancercise lady remember Daniel
you